[Music]
gary's with us gary is in kansas city hi
gary how are you
hi dave team ramsey uh
honor to speak with you you too
i wanted to uh just go over
what's in my life and my brother's lives
a little bit of a complex uh
question question we need answered
regarding uh
my mom who died a couple of months ago
and uh some of the far out from that oh
thanks what happened what did she pass
away from um
i think officially it was covet however
there was more to it she was she had a
lot on her mind she was dealing with my
dad who had dementia
she was uh
lived a life of service and entertaining
for us and just provided her life she
was very joyful person and a lot of
friends a lot of a lot of great
relationships she established and we uh
we were just blessed for a couple of
show weeks ago you mentioned uh what we
inherit from our parents you know a big
cash nest egg and all maybe that's not
so good but instead is better a
work ethic and i think we got that from
my parents god god bless them you know
uh man anyway
we miss him please her fiercely and uh
so
it's it's part of it's
so that's joy but there's a sad part
that we're trying to work through
she was scammed the last two years of
her life pretty pretty and she bought
into it bought into it pretty
pretty deeply um and we were sort of
tracking it but not real uh
not as close as we should have as i'm
remote from her i have
some some mega millions scam or
something uh
got it got into her head and uh
she was very uh concerned about you know
providing some kind of uh inheritance
for her for us
is your dad still is your dad still
alive
he is and and yes he he's with us and
my middle brother is really stepped up
and he's he's doing bad basically taking
the place of what my mom was doing so
did she lose all of their assets
in a word yes okay she sold a house
about a year and a half ago all the
proceeds spent and
there's nothing left but debt
the debt is the debt is not that so the
debt is like kind of small but it's so
where we're going with this question is
the ethics of it so
she had in this scam the the scammers
had convinced her to buy three iphone 12
and and and they would reimburse her in
all this and it was somehow how she was
going to pay the taxes as well that's
where a lot of the money apparently went
and he had a
she uh so she bought these three iphone
12s or a thousand bucks a piece and uh a
big cell company or a big uh
one of the big ones um
now has this bill out she wasn't getting
the
installments of funding that were said
to be coming from the scammers of course
so at the point where she was seeing she
bought these phones and then of course
shipped them off
uh
all at her expense
with the cell phone
provider companies whatever
they uh
they they got free two free phones she
kept one of them and now she wasn't
gonna pay the
finance and find it you know your
finance these things and then she was i
guess gonna so she didn't pay the three
thousand dollars off we still have this
three thousand dollar bill
and
there's nothing to be redeemed as far as
her credit because her credit shot she
had a great credit she did great things
with her money through her life when you
pass away gary
what you own
stands good for what you owe
and so she has a 3 000 debt does she own
[Music]
your dad and her own
anything
he's got
a car
um
there's there's little penny any stuff
that that is around a car
uh
the uh i mean there was some
some little some hard assets that were
uh able to uh
liquidate an event and that wasn't even
to be done but we weren't really uh
uh
they come after her estate that i guess
that's all they can do they can come
after her estate and if you guys sold an
antique dresser for ten thousand dollars
and kept that money instead of paying
this bill
then they would have recourse against
you guys
okay so yeah
she uh saddled us with this it sounds
like yeah what you own
stands good for what you owe when you
pass away but your kids do not inherit
debt but your kids will not get an
inheritance until the debt is paid out
of
the things that they owned your mom and
dad owned
where is your dad living
he's in a uh a memory care facility okay
all right so he's got a checking account
with three thousand dollars in it
yes there's that yeah we've got a little
bit of
my brothers and i are all if this is the
only debt that there is
you're going to have to pay that debt in
order to clear the rest of the assets
even though they're penny annie
it's not ethics it's the law
yeah okay
and they that you know they're probably
for three thousand dollars not gonna
chase you guys down and you know put you
in a headlock and and you know try to
get the three thousand bucks out of you
as a practical matter but that's
technically the way this works and so
morally the way this works
understood
yeah you're gonna you're gonna have the
unhappy experience of completing the
scam
right goodness um
okay and how prevalent is this is this a
very proud
do i need to get as i retire from my
military should i go into
uh detective work and cyber and and
regarding trying to protect elders from
their
the only problem is the people that will
be paying you are broke because they've
been scammed
uh but yeah it's pretty prevalent that's
a pretty standard the the iphone scam
you know that whole thing that's fairly
normal we hear it sadly more often than
we should and um
yeah it's
it's it's pretty prevalent but i don't
know whether you can make an income
doing it or not that's a whole other
discussion so if you suspect
that a loved one is being scammed
suggested steps
i think you have to have a sit down with
them and say hey i think something's
fishy here can we dig into this and try
not to put them on the defensive but ask
some questions dig in do a little bit of
your own version of a private
investigator and uh dive into it and
then show them hey this doesn't seem to
make a lot of sense
and many times they just need somebody
else to kind of look at it and go hey
this doesn't seem right and i think
that's the first thing i do and if it's
not right i'd say hey this is a bad idea
we're going to get you out of this let
me help you know because i think there's
a certain amount of embarrassment there
oh always think about that you know so
go in
go in a little easier i'm trying to put
myself in the shoes of talking to my
father you know if he were to have that
situation and i'm gonna have to come in
there
and not embarrass him not make him feel
like he was totally duped make the bad
guy the bad guy not them the bad guy
that would be my approach that's exactly
right that's exactly how you do it and
it's really not hard to research these
scams that's correct a simple google
search will pop up in front of you and
you know mega millions scam spanish
letter scam nigerian letter scam there's
several versions out there
and uh um
the people get sucked into all kinds of
different things and just if you just if
you have enough information you know
where there's cell phone and mega
millions both mentioned all you do is
type that in and boom it'll pop up show
you exactly what they're doing how
they're working it yeah what what's
going on and then you just can send that
link
and go listen this is what's happening
to you yeah yeah let's get you out of
there and so um you know you didn't do
anything wrong no uh you were just
trying to leave an inheritance what a
horrible
motivation
but uh the number of times i've seen
people
in the name of leaving an inheritance to
their children
get into stuff they should not get into
is over 30 years of doing this it's all
the time oh i'm sure bad financial
products
scam real straight up scams like that
lady got scammed
um but all in the name of i want to
leave the kids something which is a
misguided thing to start with the most
important thing you can leave them is to
not do that kind of stuff
yeah i just i've learned this you know
if it's too good to be true it's almost
always
if it smells fishy there's fish involved
i mean come on
you know if you think if you i got a bad
feeling you know why you gotta this this
just felt weird you know why it felt
weird because it was weird oh yeah
that's why i felt weird yeah and trust
yourself you know yeah i'm glad you said
that so you know i'm a big nerd and i
read a lot i was reading a book i'm
reading a book right now by a physicist
and you know you talk it's legendary you
talk about sharon dave's wife sharon
she's she's got incredible great great
great common sense you always talk about
that feeling you say it the way that i
can't say it but you can say it
there it is
and but you know there's actually the
physicists have done research on this
real quick they had they put heart
monitors on world-class grand master
chess players
to find out if that gut feeling is that
a gut feeling or is it actually tied to
the same mechanism that we kind of say
well i logically thought through this
decision long story short this grand
master chess player's heart rate spiked
every time in the match before they made
an incorrect move and the the so the the
conclusion was that gut feeling
that's actually your brain sending a
physical response to your body and your
heart is warning you
don't do it don't do it and so i just
wanted to point out that when you have a
bad feeling
don't put that off as a gut thing as
some mysterious thing that's your brain
and your body combining to go stop
yeah but i had a weird feeling about him
you know that's because he's weird right
you know
that's just you know that's the thing
it's just trust yourself yeah and um you
know because you know that about 20
times while that lady was sending off
that money of those cell phones and
selling her house to do this that she
had those things you know she had an
inkling
that this was wrong and so the way you
can step in is to tap into that and say
you gotta trust yourself
because yourself is telling yourself
this is not this bad deal this is a bad
thing trust yourself and i used to say
trust your gut instinct and my friend
who's a pastor said that's not your gut
that's the holy spirit don't call the
holy spirit your gut
trust god's spirit that's in you which
will speak to you and say don't do it
yeah that's it